that is baby money man checking me out
on the bootleg Kev podcast
show we got a special guest in the
building man represent the west side of
Detroit QC Zone man baby money welcome
bro it's cracking with you yeah I tried
to tap in with you when I was out in
Detroit yeah
um
yeah yo your your [ __ ] is on fire out
there
yeah it's crazy because like uh I spent
a week out there and I was it was so
different than everybody like you know I
feel like
people trying to make Detroit to be like
this crazy ass like terrible place but
when I went out there it was amazing I
loved it out there man yeah you run into
[ __ ] like that when you like looking if
you're looking for it yeah 100 but it
was it was amazing man um and a lot of
people were speaking highly of you out
there uh obviously uh
how did the QC thing happen
uh going to New York messing with my
manager and [ __ ] out there he ended up
taking me to his cousin named noodles
noodles
that went under my [ __ ] right now let
Pete here they flew me out there shots
away now
um so shout out to Bueno uh so Bueno it
was the one who kind of put you on to to
qc's radar he does the a r thing over
there and they're super tapped in with
Detroit now that they signed Icewear
Vezzo yeah yeah that's my guy fezzo a
great guy man like uh what do you think
it is about Detroit right now that's
kind of got music because I feel like
between Detroit and Memphis y'all really
kind of running rap [ __ ] yeah they
finally got a chance to just like
actually hear us
sometimes like back in the day I think
they were scared like we're gonna get
some money and just do all violence with
the money you feel what I'm saying so I
feel like now they're hearing this and
seeing like people really know how to
rap we just yeah everybody like style
actually come from our city everybody I
was gonna say Detroit's so influential
uh-huh I feel like Detroit and the Bay
Area and Cali are so influential to the
restaurant because yeah yeah Detroit and
the bear are definitely cousins so y'all
rap on the same tempo of Beats you know
what I mean like oh yeah same flavor
it's a player [ __ ] going on out in
Detroit
same time you know
Pax might get mailed
a lot of the plugs you know what I mean
it might be in the bay uh but not um
yeah like do you think
because for for me obviously growing up
like when I thought of Detroit I thought
like obviously Eminem but then uh there
was guys like Royce to five nine uh
guilty Simpson Black Milk J dilla a lot
of like slum Village yeah
um
now like I feel like
because that was kind of more boom bap
like real like rap you know traditional
hip-hop [ __ ] and now it's like the
street shooting Detroit is just kind of
running the running [ __ ] like he's
saying the picture for you for sure who
would you say was like the first artist
of this new era to kind of bring the
national attention to the city in terms
of like maybe the last five or six years
uh you gotta say tea yeah Grizzly for
sure right yeah
it should have been going crazy since
for real yeah that first day out I feel
like kicked the whole door down right it
was hard for the whole city for
everybody for sure shout out to Flint
too Flint's going crazy come on Fremont
Nigeria really uh we we uh definitely uh
got left for Rio Flint's a great
I feel like the sound's not not the same
but it's kind of like y'all you know
y'all cousins for real you guys are more
like brothers you guys are siblings
cities do you feel me Flint the same
thing yeah no more people 100 how you
get a name like baby money just always
being the youngest person around you
feel what I'm saying we are getting
money I was always the youngest person
that's how I came with her just just the
big homies gave you the name yeah every
all my friends older than me like
probably like five six years older than
me I don't really hanging people that's
how I was growing up all my like all my
best friends are like five six seven
eight years older than me so like do you
feel like that had a lot to do with kind
of like you being a lot more mature
growing up yeah cause like when I get in
the room with people my age like the
stuff that they do out now I mean like
man yeah you even do that like you feel
me yeah I don't know I probably a little
bit Advanced 100 you got a new project
coming out yeah new money September 23rd
Moon money new money oh new money okay
new money September 23rd yeah uh who
else on the album I got I got a couple
of people on there we'll save this on
there for sure everybody know JB on
there that's my brother well we'll put
this out
the Monday after the album drops so you
can tell us who's on the album All right
so who's on the album all right Jeezy
you got Jeezy on there Jeezy yeah okay
oh [ __ ] and for people who don't know
Jeezy you know Doughboys cash I was was
on CT City our city like they love Jeezy
fans for sure
yeah not so much Rick Ross
I just think back to the time that they
stopped it from going to that show that
but you know Jeezy you know Jeezy all
his music he rap about Detroit he calls
his second home so we just show him the
same little back and he gave a big
opportunity to a legendary group out the
city
yeah you know payroll Giovanni's going
crazy doing staying shout out to him
both y'all from the West Side what would
you say is the biggest difference
between uh the west side of Detroit and
the east side of Detroit uh
we both get money they just grind like
they they wear Dickie fishing [ __ ] we
were we were we'll put Fashion on the
ground in it you feel what I'm saying
like for another example they rap
different we rap flashy they rap about
the track we all rap about the Trappers
just just hide this this how it is you
feel what I'm saying would you say it's
kind of like if you think of New York
you think of Harlem being like the
flashy fashion like so the west side is
kind of like the Harlem of Detroit yeah
that makes sense yeah this uh when you
were growing up did you listen to Eminem
at all no I ain't started listening to
him until like a year ago you know that
like what's that one song like that you
only get your chance to blow I never
actually listened to what he was talking
about on that yeah I finally listened to
him Lose Yourself yeah Lose Yourself so
when I find it this is dude when I was
hearing what he was saying I'm like all
right like this hard for real for real
it's so wild that like this whole like
new generation of Detroit artists like
just like Eminem wasn't a big influence
he's a daddy in Eight Mile two he's in
the movie yeah I'll be right behind him
about the last battle going against so
he's he's at the shelter in the battle
your dad's in the video he ain't rapping
no but he's in the background can you
point him out when you watch the movie
yeah you got a black mink on you just
gotta look right behind him that's crazy
so did you watch Eight Mile obviously as
a kid you had to watch it yeah the whole
series your [ __ ] dad's in it man I
don't even know that until I got older
for real for real like he got a check
for that [ __ ] and everything he got a
check yeah for playing in the movie
that's amazing
being I mean yeah extras get paid for
sure damn that's [ __ ] dope I'll tell
you this much I went to his spaghetti
restaurant yeah it's terrible
it's God awful so where some of the
worst Food I've ever eaten I've never
been there yet me and uh the shitty boys
went uh
uh shout out to Baby Tron from Detroit
we went there and uh we tried this
spaghetti and it was
not good
it feels like the kind of place only
like Taurus to like I wouldn't even let
everybody make my spaghetti for real for
real like you got your own way I know
like you know your mama make the
spaghetti that's the spaghetti you eat
they ain't gonna make it how your mama
ain't that the truth that's that's real
what so
what's the best Coney Island in Detroit
best Coney Island in Detroit probably L
George's is that in your area hey that's
west side it's on Six Mile okay we got
mail George's for sure for people who
don't know what a Coney Island is who
aren't from Detroit because I I kind of
had an idea what I knew it was a type of
hot dog but it's also just a whole
restaurant it's a real restaurant yeah
and like they're everywhere in Detroit
every corner main things is settling is
chili dogs that's why yeah but there's
also Wings there they got breakfast
omelets cheesecake all kinds of like a
real restaurant yeah it's crazy but
they're everywhere like y'all don't got
like out here where I stayed the only
people with them too like in fact
because out here we got taco trucks out
there y'all got the Coney Island joints
every corner probably every mile for
real sure I never see nothing like it
you guys also have a place
that is like a fake Raising Canes what's
that place called Uncle Joe's or
what Captain Jay's Captain Jay's yeah
it's like Raising Canes right oh my God
I don't think it's like racing games
same sauce
I'll tell you there's like two locations
yeah no uh baby Tron took us to this
place it was so it was insane yeah
I also gotta say Detroit's got the most
beautiful black women I've ever seen in
my life
everyone's fine in Detroit it's crazy
bro I'm at the MGM Grand like that's
where we were staying I was like geez
everybody what's up well everybody being
fine they are buses too yeah it's crazy
it's crazy man who would you say your
biggest influences were growing up just
being a rapper uh rapping yeah
my brother was rapping first my brother
Dominos rapping first
he stopped rapping when he got out of
high school but like I say Blade icewood
Street Lord I listened to Biggie Tupac
shout out to me Lord he's a great guy
man he took care of us while I was out
there yeah that's my guy yeah Team
Eastside Doughboy cash out though for
sure yeah that's my age when I was like
13 that's who had the city unlocked you
tapping with uh with little blade a
little Blair smoker good good kid oh my
God we got to hang out with him for a
little bit out there yeah cool [ __ ]
yeah super cool dude man do you feel
like uh Detroit's moving more
together now because it feels that way
yeah it ain't like no hating going on
especially with this musician [ __ ]
uplifting each other because I feel like
a few years ago like you would always
hear everybody in Detroit was beefing
but I feel like everybody for the most
part is kind of moving in the right
direction right now I I think people see
that it's like it's enough money for
everybody you know points like look at
what Atlanta did people getting signed
everybody's getting signed and like if
you just look at look at the city like
Atlanta Atlanta park because everybody
was moving together it's like it's like
it's like if you at the casino you think
you about to get the whole billion
that's in the building right be greedy
why would you gonna get go ahead
100 yeah the city's going crazy man
um we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our folks at my
bookie ladies and gentlemen
[ __ ] NFL season is approaching
it's my favorite time of the year God
damn it it's good times and the Rams
versus the bills is happening kicking
off the whole regular season and there's
no way to get ready for that regular
season like getting ready for that
winning season all right I'm talking
about putting some [ __ ] money
in your pocket you could be a veteran
better like me or you could be a first
time better and you just want to get a
little taste of the action my bookie has
got you because right now they got that
double deposit bonus if you sign up at
mybookie.ag right now go to my bookie
it's quick and easy let's say you put
250 bucks in you get 500 to gamble with
that's right it's a double deposit bonus
but you have to use the promo code
bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g it's also in the
description of this video you can just
click the link and you're in there so go
to mybookie.com use that double deposit
bonus by using the promo code bootleg
you got to register today use it and
let's get this NFL season [ __ ]
cracking I'm talking listen I don't even
know the line of the Rams Bills game
it's about a week out on some change
away depending on what the [ __ ] you're
watching this but
Bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put a hundred
you get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview you would recent we were
talking and then you ended up locked up
yeah obviously you got out what'd you
get locked up for that's some [ __ ]
it was really a violation probation
violation you're past it now no I'm
still you're still you're still on
papers [ __ ] ain't going doing no
[ __ ] or nothing that's good what
what was it smoking or what was it some
some dumb [ __ ]
smoking weed in a state that it's legal
yeah they take that [ __ ] serious out
there isn't it recreational though yeah
about that in Michigan it is
recreational right
yeah should you get like a randomly piss
tested now yeah
do they do they do the color system like
were they just like like is it just it's
totally random you have no heads up
right yeah if you wake up and they say
you got to come in you got to come in
how long are you on papers
better be make your life a lot easier
you'll be able to move around a lot
easier and have to check game in listen
yeah your shits are really about to go
crazy too so it's like you gotta perfect
timing yeah yeah hell yeah how is the QC
experience been man man fire I already
didn't expect this [ __ ] like there's
some cities that you always talk about
but you don't think it's gonna come to
life so when it happened it already blow
your mind then you're around the people
that you was already listening to as a
kid right in the same rooms these people
got the same opportunities them too you
just gotta make sure you do your job
yeah they're like really the craziest
rap label we've had in like the last
like 15 20 years yeah it's crazy it is
crazy Lana yeah it is dope too to see
like they're they're like a real effort
in Detroit to like you know and they
actually pushed their artists that's a
good thing they do a hundred percent no
matter which like you said like whether
it's little baby where there's you
whether it's whoever it is they're put
like they're they're not a lot of uh
labels assign people and really kind of
waste people's time
like some people don't be working though
at the same that's true sometimes people
sign and they think that the work's over
they got the paper they got the bag now
though that's when the work starts
it's a whole start over it's like you
started nobody starting over got through
the street phase now you you and this
big you in this big room now so it's
like what's gonna make you stand out 100
is that something that like when you
were
when you first signed it they have that
talk with you because you already just
kind of know like no now no yes I'm not
no off top yeah what's some game that um
those guys have given you obviously uh
shout out to QC they're both of them
dudes are
bosses for real like any game that you
that you took with you from from p and
those guys you say your money stay on
your [ __ ] and keep working yeah
are you being uh pretty you know we just
lost pnb Rock obviously rest in peace um
we've been losing a lot of artists we've
been losing a lot of people just and not
even just losing people but just [ __ ] is
crazy out especially in L.A obviously
shit's crazy everywhere
um are you pretty conscientious about
how you move now like where you are
where you end up at like I was like that
before that though um like you already
got to be on your shoe no matter where
you go everybody look at la like a
tourist site though you feel me they
want to come see the Hollywood stuff the
[ __ ] that we see in the movies that's
why you feel me so you got to know where
you at that's the main thing what I
noticed too is when you came in you
didn't have your chain on
you put your chain on for the interview
which makes sense oh yeah because that
would then because of that well I mean I
mean I'm just saying I if it was because
that'd be smart because if you're just
rolling around because of that I'm gonna
walk out with this [ __ ] okay I'm
just saying I mean I I know that I was
like that's smart I'm not saying that
you're scared if I was an artist I would
I would just I wouldn't be wearing that
[ __ ] if I was going to 7-Eleven
see then some people just make some dumb
mistakes and just go yeah you ain't got
to work everywhere you ain't going
nowhere I'm coming from the room what do
you think is the biggest misconception
about your city man
everybody thinks it's a bad thing they
think like we gonna come [ __ ] something
up soon as we get there it's really cool
it's a lot of [ __ ] you can see a lot of
food you can eat a lot of people you can
meet too you feel if you're looking for
the [ __ ] that's when the [ __ ]
comes
you'll attract what you're looking for
for sure there's so many clubs out there
you can go to like enjoy yourself like
nothing gonna happen they're not gonna
get shot up like people think what was
that area is it little grease or a
little uh
uh the area that we drove through this
with the strip of bars downtown
Greektown Greektown Casino
there's yeah there's like a strip of
like restaurants and bars
called Greektown right yeah it ain't no
strip clubs though no no no strip clubs
but when we went down there the security
dude was telling she's like hey don't go
to Greektown by herself I was like we
drove through it like this [ __ ] looks
like some tourist [ __ ] like I don't know
shots of hey great food out there at the
strip clubs great food good show for so
what would be your if somebody were to
go to Detroit would be the one
restaurant that they'd have to eat at
you got the culture Midwest Grill it'd
be like the street the street foods out
there like the people from there and got
their own restaurants like you're pretty
tapped in with the Pistons yeah I know a
couple you know you [ __ ] with Kate
Cunningham yet I already know him like
that I'll be watching them though
Isaiah Stewart that's the guy who got
into the he almost [ __ ] fought LeBron
that's my girl yeah hey worst case
scenario could be your security
in the off season that dude that dude
looks like he ain't the one to play with
that's my you gotta how you feeling
about the Pistons young team great
pieces we should we should do good this
year you're a big basketball fan yeah
yeah I hope all my life lions are you a
lions guy I really watch football like
that well I guess when you grow up in
Detroit and the lions are the worst
[ __ ] NFL franchise of all time I used
to go there as a kid though like I used
to go to the games I just never played
football right I'm a big big basketball
if they were really good you probably
would be a fan though for sure for sure
yeah for sure I feel bad for Lions I got
a couple of my homies with Detroit and
they're Die Hard lines I'm like damn
that's rough so you remember that if we
get one this year long you're trying to
be on our y'all won't though y'all won't
y'all got Jared Goff is your quarterback
y'all they get [ __ ]
Detroit's a crazy sports city though
like every y'all got every team
hockey [ __ ] baseball basketball and
everything I'm like one street it's all
right there yeah yeah Little Caesars
Arena Tiger Stadium Tiger Stadium looked
like a Vibe yeah it's all right there
most places you go to like the city like
in the football stadiums like 35 minutes
away from downtown or shit's always
spread out for everything right there
off the freeway
um what would you say now that you you
know you see the light at the end of the
tunnel with this rap career [ __ ] would
you say there was ever a low point in
your rapping career where you did not
know if it was worth the time or the
investment to continue pursuing it
no not for real because I was actually
doing it for fun I was actually doing it
because I wanted to do it so you're
doing it just because you wanted to do
it like whether or not you were making
money on it didn't matter yeah we're
doing about that to start I found out
about this throwing somebody told me
about like you put your music on there
so even if I didn't make no money they
wasn't gonna stop me from not making
music yeah sure were you just like
flooding like we do it like like give me
the breakdown of like your your come up
like where you dropping mixtapes just
heavy on YouTube more videos there I
probably got like 40 videos so you were
just diving in on YouTube tough real
tough that was the thing back in the day
keep dropping videos try to get 10K
views 10K like you're the man right
that's a bay 10K is a 10K that's serious
yeah right now that's the that's the new
hundred thousand on the song 100 000
comes so quick on this phone yeah yeah
yeah yeah are you noticing like uh
is it is it is it better to let me ask
you this because if you're an
independent artist you've been an
independent artist is it better to shoot
the low budget video and get a bunch of
them or shoot the drop a bag on like the
set the [ __ ] clothes actors whatever
and shoot a high budget video but not
maybe have the money to shoot a bunch
more I don't know you can make a low
budget video look like a lot nowadays
though you would hope so yeah if you got
the right yeah space
is fire you can make a [ __ ] look like a
lot off another 100 man
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Blue chew they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick Bluetooth
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
mean like LeBron his first three seasons
with the heat type levels I mean your
wife will thank you for it everybody
will thank you for it [ __ ] even if you
just take a Bluetooth and jerk your dick
it's a it's a stronger jerk I swear to
God stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're
gonna be beating your dick like a stole
something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discrete
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
thank me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the Bluetooth he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview you know the
craziest thing I saw we stopped at a
liquor store uh on the west side
it was like a One-Stop shop I don't
remember where it was you probably have
like they had pizza they had [ __ ] bed
in the back corner of the store they had
the um they had the fake weed bags for
sale you know what I'm talking about
yeah yeah there's a lot of stoves like
that though like yes you go to the back
of the store and you got hookah spots in
them it's just a lot of them yo so you
could buy like uh I think each bag's a
dollar
or maybe less five for a dollar and like
you could buy like fake cookies fake
like London pound cake lemonade like
fake runts so you just buy the bags and
you just put whatever boof you got into
the bags in The Old City hustle that's a
beautiful thing man tell somebody it's
Calvin until someone hits California and
they know the difference
damn I've been [ __ ] smoking [ __ ]
this whole time man what do you do in
your spare time like if you're at home
chilling like what are your hobbies man
outside of making music basketball I'm
about to get into working out for real
but I'll be playing best you be hooping
what position I was a point guard when I
was hooping ah [ __ ] so you were like
running the show
Isaiah hey Isaiah Thomas one of the
greatest of all time for this show shout
out to uh who do you think's the best
point guard ever though the best point
guard yeah I don't know it's called your
point guard not a shooting guard
shooting guard all right I'll give it to
eyeball probably who Iverson oh Iverson
AI really okay
I was it was nice he wasn't incredible
he had I had all his shoes growing up
then Reeboks man them answers the threes
the answer threes were crazy yeah I was
into the Jordans all right but I mean
yeah I really could have you know the
one thing about Iverson his shoes were a
lot more affordable than Jordan's so I
had him I had a lot of those and the
feedlers Grant Hill had some feelers
foreign
I love that the Pistons are bringing
back those uh the jerseys this year the
um the teal ones from the 90s oh yeah I
didn't know that yeah they're bringing
it back some other jerseys I got like a
blue stripe red stripe on them I can't
see those now but shots
so you play basketball you watch any
like TV binge watching any shows
I'll be on YouTube all day so you just
dive into YouTube rabbit holes yeah I'm
just writing listening to music I don't
watch the documentaries all type of
stuff what's the right most random [ __ ]
you've learned on YouTube or a rabbit
hole that you've dived down just
watching yeah cause like you'll watch
one video and then the next one will be
suggested you watching uh dumbest
criminals oh yeah you're watching all
that type of [ __ ] on there just like
True Crime uh-huh yeah like you said
like he's getting kidnapped on there you
watching like damn why that happened
yeah no YouTube is uh that algorithm is
the best out of all the apps because
you'll just open your app if you're
signed in and you'll be like oh there's
a bunch of just a bunch of [ __ ] I want
to watch stay on YouTube just need Wi-Fi
smart TV that's true YouTube's the best
you watch a lot of podcasts
not free I watch a what's that one
podcast up
I watch Gillian and [ __ ] yeah a million
stars worth of game shout out to us I
just saw wallow did where's
wallows his fire shot normally watching
this [ __ ] for sure yeah wallowing those
guys I feel like they're pretty heavily
tapped in out there too showing up to
that right guy yeah he's a great guy man
he coming by herself every state solo
that's [ __ ] crazy yes who would you
put uh on your Detroit Mount Rushmore of
rap
four slots blade icewood me
damn
they are Detroit Detroit only blade
icewood me
as of right now they nice with me
probably Ray
baby face Ray Ray
Vis this four P really got to be on that
[ __ ] too though
um
PC going crazy right now for sure for
sure for sure
do you think like uh when you when you
see uh
the influence from Detroit like and you
hear it other places because I feel like
it's been happening a lot more recently
do you do you guys give a [ __ ] to try
and get like the recognition that like a
lot of [ __ ] is originating from there or
is it just like ah nah yeah we hear our
influence it's good to know it's
affecting everybody we thought they were
skipping over but they really looking at
us at this point for sure people people
are still pop out with some of the [ __ ]
that come from the city and they go
bigger before because they ain't see it
from us first yeah no you're right it's
crazy because like you said everyone's
getting signed uh you 42 Doug T Grizzly
[ __ ] pz has been running it up with
Empire
shout out to uh Bodie James who's doing
his thing on the on the boom bap [ __ ]
like him and Alchemist got some Classics
together so you know Detroit's going
crazy man uh how dope was it like when
you first heard the Jeezy verse that you
got was it like surreal to hear like oh
[ __ ] Jeezy got hopped on my [ __ ] yeah it
[ __ ] me up because I was locked up I
heard it over the phone oh [ __ ] like man
what so they just put it up to the phone
yeah yeah that's crazy how long were you
in you weren't in for long you were like
in and out right 45 days yeah in and out
got right back to it not going back
that's good to hear you got to stay free
man this is not too much money would you
ever consider moving out of Detroit
I don't know where I want to go yet yeah
but that's the plan yeah I feel like
sometimes you get more hate where you're
from than anywhere else that's automatic
especially with this [ __ ] especially
with the rap [ __ ] especially with the
rap [ __ ] man it's it's it's it's crazy
out here bro it's like
um damn
so when you were growing up
do you feel like you always knew you
wanted to do music or was it something
more that you just kind of fell into
because I just fell into that I was
playing basketball so you were like a
serious ball player yeah every that's
all I did you feel me so uh it went from
me playing basketball than me making
money then dropping out to me just going
to the studio with my brother's enough
to have fun
and it was just so much fun you're like
I'm gonna just do this because I like it
yeah because they taught me how to I'm a
quick learner they taught me how to make
faux bars like I do not make full bars
around four lines around yeah and when I
seen it was easy it just kept doing it
yeah when my brother died it made me
just press it more like damn so your
brother that rap passed away no he don't
even rap He was just somebody who pushed
me okay okay to keep going all my other
brothers wrapped up but he was just the
person who'd be in the studio you know
when I did my version like no you got to
make songs by yourself oh so he would
like kind of like help direct you like
Yo dude you should do it this way type
[ __ ] yeah his name Sosa I had crumbs my
other brother somebody like make me get
off the block like no get in the car
with me I'm paying for the studio time
so you would say he was like a big
motivation to keep you out the streets
for sure when he passed away you dive
all the way in on this [ __ ] hell yeah
yeah damn sometimes man you got to take
what you can it's positive out of
tragedy
hundred percent man
um so how serious were you with
basketball like do you feel like you
could have like played college yeah yeah
you saw I grew up like Derek coming the
basketball player I grew up with him
like Derek Coleman was he your coach no
he owned our team and [ __ ] so I was
playing with his son okay okay like my
uncle though like for real Derrick
Coleman's a legendary power forward
because like my uncle good Derek Coleman
is what's he like as a dude nice guy
yeah he built that's how we started
hooping he built the park in our Hood
wow he had a camp up there to where
every day like seven in the morning you
hoop from seven to like four in the
afternoon is he from he from 12th yeah
okay that's dope shout out to Derrick
Coleman I didn't know that yeah he's
he's like 80s early 90s OG he was a
beast he was a [ __ ] muscle like that
[ __ ] was was not not the one to
play with
an enforcer you know what I mean that's
crazy we got to stop the interview tell
you about our partners at Odd Socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at these the bootleg Kev sock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
gonna figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been rocking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
Odd Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview uh
all right so this new album is coming
out uh well by the time you're watching
this it'll be out
um new money new money September 23rd
about 16 songs are fired 16 records
would you and Vezzo do a collab tape I
don't know it might happen you never
know I feel like with that smile it's
already happening you never know it's
already happening I don't know that
would make sense you guys are both on
the same label both from the same city
both fire it can't happen how many songs
in the uh or just in the cut you all
have together that are that aren't out
you got that man not that many no no
have you been able to uh you know he's
somebody who kind of inspires me because
uh
you know when he got out of jail man he
just really got to it and uh so he ain't
stopped yet yeah and and you know even
though he had that Motown situation that
kind of ended up not working out
he he when he left Motown he really
turned up and just the
you know his he's just expanding into
movies and he's got his potato chips
the Vapes we went to the liquor store
out there and he had Vapes and chips in
that [ __ ] and the chips were
fire for sure have you had the chips
super good I'll be under attacking them
all the time buying boxes yeah shots and
I ain't buying them off like because
that's my God bottom because they good
though of course they're good they're
amazing yeah what's your favorite uh
flavor of Faygo Faygo probably grape
Moon Miss is like something really
that's like a moon missed this fire it's
like our Mountain Dew so I tried the
moon Mist out there yeah Moon Mist was
gas what was the other one that we liked
it was kind of like a like it was like a
blue box was the moon missed in the blue
box it's a blue moon is still it's two
of them yeah we tried that one and we
tried the uh the bomb pop one it's like
white red and blue yeah I hate that [ __ ]
so sweet oh that [ __ ] is sweet that [ __ ]
is diabetes in a bottle
that [ __ ] is crazy uh shout out to Faygo
though you got to get a Faygo
sponsorship yeah for sure you gotta
Faygo sponsor your first tour or
something for me right now when I was
growing up uh we only knew Faygo because
of Insane Clown Posse
you said what have you ever heard of
Insane Clown Posse ICP they're from uh
they're from Detroit area you know never
heard of the Juggalos uh that's probably
dirty some white people [ __ ] Bro some
like real like
it's a group man I gotta show you
because this is crazy they're like a
legendary independent group from out
there
their music is not um the best though
it's uh insane
but they have like a crazy they're fan
base they're called Juggalos the FBI
designated the Juggalos as a gang in the
90s
um
were they rapping yeah they're rapping
like [ __ ] but these guys
hell no I ain't never seen that
I ain't nervous I don't know that so
when they would perform they used to
launch uh two liters of Faygo into the
crowd so the whole [ __ ] crowd would
be sticky that's crazy but that's like I
didn't know about I only knew about I
always thought Faygo was like their soda
brand and and then I grew up I found out
it's just a Detroit soda brand yeah and
then when we went to Detroit I'm like
they got 58 [ __ ] flavors at every
store that's our regular product it's
like their variation is crazy like
there's so many different flavors of
soda it's it's wild yeah uh well look
man go run up the album it's out now by
the time you're watching this yeah I'm
gonna be out so go run that [ __ ] up uh
go get that hopefully we get a Vezzo
collab tape let's go put that in the air
you never know
shout out to my guy baby money Detroit
uh
yes sir